[موسيقى]
هكذا يبدو مركز مدينه موسكو مستعدا
للاحتفال بعيدي الميلادي وراس السنه في
وقت تدخل فيه عمليه البلاد العسكريه
الخاصه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه شهر هل
العاشره
وقال حربي محزن للغايه او للاسف الحرب
شيئا واقع ومتكرر في الحياه التاريخ يعيد
نفسه ولا يمكن للاسف تغييره هذا
اما العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف ها هي شجره
الميلاد في ساحه القديسه صوفيه تقف مزينه
تتركز على ضوء خافت من مولد يعمل بالوقود
ولفترات محدوده ولاول مره بالوال العالم
الاوكراني وفي مكان نجمه الميلاد رمز
الدوله الاوكرانيه وعلى الرغم من غياب
خيام الحلوى والمشروبات الساخنه
والاحتفالات وباحات التزلجين الا ان بهجه
الاعياد حاضره رغما عن ظروف الحرب
الحلوه والمشروبات الساخنه لكن على اي حال
يجب ان نحافظ على روحي اعياد الميلاد لان
شبابنا المقاتلين في الجبهات يريدون ان
يواصل الناس حياتهم
في موسكو المكان والزمان يحكيان مفارقه
كبيره الزينه والاضواء تملان كل ارجاء
المدينه لاعاده البهجه والفرح للمواطن
الروسي في ظل الاوضاع الراهنه خاصه ان
الشريط الحدوديه للبلاد يعيش حاله توتر
وسقوط عشرات الصواريخ يوميه
اوكرانيين الذين يعتبرون اهلنا لكل روسي
اقرباء في اوكرانيا ونحن شعب واحد وهذه
حقيقه وواقع في الرافضه للاستسلام تبحث عن
ما يمكن ان يطفي روحها اعياد الميلاد في
المدينه فكانت الحاجه ام الاختراع لذا
ابتكرت محطه قطاراته هذه الفكره تمام مع
وضع العظام الطاقه ده دراجه رياضيه تحول
الطاقه الحركيه الى كهرباء لتضيء شجره
الميلاد التي تزين صاله الركاب
رائع جدا انا ارى في ضوء هذه الشجره
بلادنا الحره المستقله اعياد الميلاد
هي التي لا طالما زقزقت فيها شمعه راس
السنه الجديده ورقص على انغامي تمنيات
بالحبي والسلام بعد ان كانت شوارعها سابقا
ترقص وتغني بزينه العيد ويختلط ليلها
بنهارها بمشهد الرائعه ها هي كيف تقابل
اعياد الميلاد والاسر الاوكرانيه في حاله
من الشتات فالنساء والاطفال غادروا بلادهم
والرجال منتشرون على الجبهات والباقوله
يواجهون اوضاع الانسانيه كارثيه ولسان
حالهم يقول باي حال عدت يا عيد